a lot of people don't know what america
is joe biden just made this statement
joe biden came out he said
it's impossible to define what america
is
i've often said that america is the only
nation in the world
founded on an idea every other nation in
the world is founded on base of either
that that your geography or
or ethnicity or religion
you can define every almost everyone
else based on those
characteristics but you can't define
america
i defy you to tell me what constitutes
an american
you can't do it we're an incredibly
diverse democracy
but there is one thing that does define
us as a country
we are founded on an idea that we hold
these truths to be self-evident
but all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator with certain
inalienable rights
pause it right there did you catch the
contradiction
i i bet a lot of people didn't catch the
i mean you you the listener i'm sure did
but a lot of people listening to joe
biden's
droning half asleep speech probably did
not he said
you can't define americans by their
religion
you can't you can't you can't i defy you
to define an american by his religion
no it's defined by an idea that all
men are created equal and endowed by
their creator with certain unalienable
rights
uh hold on sounds kind of religious to
me
you know what is what are religions
religions have ideas they make certain
claims
about history perhaps about the the
world about ideas about
what what this whole world is who we are
in relation to the world
america first of all america is not just
an idea america has a creedal aspect to
her character but it's not just an idea
it's also geography it's also
specific people it's also like things
that have happened
you know it's also the sea to shining
sea and the great plains
and all these things but there is a
creedal aspect to a character
and that creedal aspect is a religious
idea that
by definition excludes other ideas
if our country is founded on the idea
that
all men are created equal and endowed by
our creator with certain unalienable
rights
then america excludes atheism it
excludes it
it's not part of the american idea if
you are
a militant die-hard
atheist we need to get religion out of
all aspects of
public life you are anti-american i'm
sorry to tell you that if you are one
i'm not saying if you're one of these
amiable
sort of agnostic types who just says
whatever i don't really i'm saying if
you are
knocked down the ten commandments at the
courthouses kind of atheist you're
anti-american
according to joe biden's own logic
because america was founded on an idea
right and the idea is a religious idea
that god endowed us with rights so that
yeah i can i can at least define an
american in that way
what is an american i did not not bound
by race well that's true i mean there
were you know you can trace racial
groups in the country was settled by
englishmen
right that's just a fact of history
america was settled by englishmen
then you know some irish came in then
some
you know you'd say there were obviously
african slaves brought over but they
were not considered citizens for quite a
long time
uh there was bloody civil war to resolve
that problem and then
you had some some waves of migration
and then you tamped down on migration we
had effectively closed borders for a
long time
so yeah you can you can kind of trace
these things well what binds us together
then
one that religious idea uh how about
language we do increasingly we speak
other languages in this country
but we speak english right it's all our
documents are written in english all our
founding documents
are written in english we speak english
on the street
so that binds us together if you don't
speak english
better learn it because america speaks
english
for now and we should we're going to
speak one language or another words are
necessarily
exclusive and discriminatory they
discern one thing from another so you
better learn it
and if you can't speak english you are
putting yourself
outside of the american tradition
freedom requires limits as i have said
many many times now joe biden doesn't
understand that and he's just giving us
his two cents he's actually given us
his 16 cents the biden administration
actually
bragged i'm not joking actually bragged
that the cost of a fourth of july
cookout is down this year i said because
thanks to the policies of joe biden
the cost of a fourth of july cookout is
down
you know how much 16 cents
they put this the white house social
media accounts
put out a graphic that said the cost of
a fourth of july cookout in 2021 is down
16 cents from last year gas is through
the roof by the way so you can
but even if it were even if even if you
actually have
what is that to brag about that's the
best they could come up with
because the country is doing much much
worse under joe biden
that's it and it's not even just the
money by the way you know
obviously i want our economy to thrive i
want people to to be able to be doing
well and support their families
but there's more to it and this is a
mistake the right has made by
by focusing exclusively on economic
matters and
plugging gdp up you know for for
any and all excuses to do that without
any question about the wisdom of that
whether we ship jobs overseas whether we
completely open up the border it's
totally fine there are cultural issues
here that matter too
even when the the cultural conservatives
say politics is downstream of culture
well okay then
there's more to life than 16 cents i
think
i think that's more the question is who
are we as a country
a country is going to be defined not by
its expansiveness
but by its limits no matter how
expansive the country is no matter how
broad-minded the country is whether it's
very narrow-minded very broad-minded the
thing that will define it will be the
limits
a nation is defined by its borders a
culture is defined
by the borders of what it believes what
it
thinks about itself what it says this is
why speech
is so fundamental i think this is why
the book hit number one on amazon
why my book speechless controlling words
controlling mindset number one it's
because
it's not just i think the book is really
terrific but i think it's because we
know that this issue is
is what's at stake here this issue is
going to define
the country what is it that we
say what is it that we believe what is
it that we're celebrating
on the fourth of july for those of us
who celebrate it hey hold up i hope you
liked that clip if you did we got a
whole episode america goes through
puberty that's the title of the episode
i'm not just stating that but i am still
it is true
matthew mcconaughey made a good point
head on over ring the bell subscribe
check out the full episode
you can also get it on apple podcast
google play stitcher on the michael
knowles show podcast and you can also
order
my book which hit number one on all
books on amazon thanks to wonderful
readers like you
speechless controlling words controlling
minds i'll see you next time